if you're familiar with the virtual
console or emulators then you probably
use restore points every now and then to
get through eight games harder levels
unfortunately if you're hoping to do
this with pokemon red blue and yellow
when they rerelease on the Nintendo 3ds
then you're out of luck Nintendo has
uploaded the Japanese Virtual Console
manuals for all three of these games and
according to Siliconera this feature is
absent what does that mean well if you
pick up red yellow or blue you're gonna
get an authentic experience you won't be
able to save during battles or a
stressful attempt to catch a legendary
Pokemon the original three pokemon games
will re-release februari 27th which is
the 20th anniversary of the series want
more Pokemon news well there will be a
Pokemon advertisement during the Super
Bowl and polk n tournament will include
a classic Mewtwo fighter what you want
more all right well pokemon style new 3d
esas are launching with red yellow and
blue and there's a massive 3d open-world
Pokemon game coming to wii u just
kidding but if that ever happens stay
tuned gamespot and you'll be the first
to know